for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy in
the previous video we talked about or at
least we mentioned gluco genic and
ketogenic amino acids and in this video
I'm going to define them and talk about
them a little bit so when I think of
glucose genic amino acids I think about
how their carbon skeleton can be used to
make glucose via quickly neo Genesis so
specifically when it comes to click on
genic the glucose genic amino acids they
are the amino acids that give rise
directly to the following key products
alpha keto boot array structure no co a
fumarate oxaloacetate and pyruvate ok
and why is that that's because the
carbons of these intermediates can end
up in oxaloacetate right especially this
one that means that is oxaloacetate
which in the reason why that's important
is because oxaloacetate is an
intermediate of gluconeogenesis ok so if
they if the carbons can end up in
oxaloacetate that means they can end up
in glucose ok now notice that that's
five of the six key products it's all of
them except acetyl co a ok and that
brings me to ketogenic amino acids so
but I think of ketogenic amino acids I
think about how their carbon skeleton
can be used to make ketone bodies via
keto Genesis so the ketogenic amino
acids are the amino acids whose carbon
skeleton gives rise directly to acetyl
co a and why is that well because the
acetyl co a carbons they'll end up
either they'll either end up oxidized as
carbon dioxide or they'll end up in
those ketone bodies they don't end up in
oxaloacetate they can't
okay so now the question is now that we
know Google Jenica and ketogenic are
which amino acid which amino acids are
which and is there any overlap okay so
let's check out this chart below okay so
there are 13 exclusively gluco genic
amino acids there are two amino acids
that are exclusively ketogenic and then
there are five that are both glucose
Enoch and ketogenic the ones that are
exclusively glucose in it cuz there's 13
of them they're harder to memorize so
I'm gonna show you them okay we got
glycine alanine valine I'm finding
prolene
histidine arginine asparagine the
sparked a glutamine glutamate serine and
cysteine those the 13 now they're
exclusively gluco genic because the key
product they give rise to they can only
give rise to one of those five that I
mentioned before all of them any key
product other than acetyl co a so
glycine gives rise to pyruvate alanine
to pyruvate valine gives rise to sorry
valine valine gives rise to
succinylcholine Matheny gives rise to
succinylcholine alpha ketoglutarate
histidine alpha ketoglutarate
arginine alpha q rate asparagine
oxaloacetate sparked a lot state
glutamine alpha ketoglutarate glutamate
Al Queda would rate serine pyruvate and
serine also pyruvate none of those are
acetyl co ways none of these amino acids
give rise directly to acetylcholine
okay so they are exclusively Clicquot
genic now there are two that are
exclusively ketogenic and they are
specifically leucine and lysine
they only give rise directly to acetyl
co a okay so it's it's hard to memorize
13 things or at least harder to memorize
13 things that it is to memorize - so
with with the ketogenic white the
exclusively ketogenic amino acids
there's only two of them and they both
start with L and those are the
only two amino acids are with letter L
and so I think ll and that makes me
think of LL Cool J who was this hip-hop
artist that some of you may know
something you might not know anyway when
I think of LL Cool J I think of okay
ketogenic there's a K in there how about
LL Cool K where the K just stands for
ketogenic so that's how I remember
leucine and lysine being the exclusively
ketogenic amino acids okay now that was
some that are both glucose anak and
ketogenic there's five of them they are
phenylalanine isoleucine threonine
tryptophan and tyrosine okay now they
are both glucose and again ketogenic
because they all can give rise to acetyl
co a as well at least as well as to at
least one of the other five key products
so phenylalanine gives rise to fumarate
in addition to physio co a isoleucine
gives rise to succinylcholine in
addition to acetyl co a and then
threonine to pyruvate and
succinylcholine in addition to acetyl co
a tryptophan to pyruvate as well as
acetyl co a and tyrosine to fumarate as
well as to acetylcholine so keeping it
with the whole 1-letter situation like
we did over here with the ll ll here we
can also think about it like that
because there are only three amino acids
i start with the letter T so all the T's
are here okay there's only one that
starts I so that's that one isoleucine
and then there's just pee here
phenylalanine so some people do just
remember as p ittt soap it I don't like
that though because phenylalanine starts
with the P but so does prolene so some
people can get that confused so what I
do instead is just use the one letter
code for phenylalanine which is F and so
that B that is fit so you can use either
one obviously it's your choice but I
totally prefer this because that P gets
confusing okay but either one works
point is two to know which ones are
which and this is kind of important to
keep this in mind right which ones are
glucose genic which ones are ketogenic
and which ones
both okay so when we look at this just
to kind of visualize it in terms of the
big picture we can see that the ones
that are are gluco genic are in pink the
ones that are both are blue and the ones
that are or light pink is equipo genetic
because there's also this pink anyway
light pink gluco genic the orange
ketogenic and then blues for both so
what you'll notice is that leucine and
lysine they're exclusively ketogenic
they only show up here they give rise
directly to acetyl co a and they don't
show up anywhere else in these boxes now
with the glucose genic ones it's not
just the exclusively glucose genic ones
so notice that the ones here
phenylalanine isoleucine and the three
T's they show up there as well as giving
rise to acetyl co way as well as to
somewhere else else in these other pink
boxes so notice that felony is here as
well as here right so it's ketogenic up
here gluto genic here we've got
isoleucine here we've also got it here
so it's again ketogenic as well as
glucose genic we've got three in here
and here and somewhere over here yep
right there okay so it's again again
ketogenic and then we've got tryptophan
over here and here and we've also got
tyrosine there and there and so that
that these are the ones that are both
show up giving rise to SCO Kuwait as
well as to some other intermediate
whereas the Kukla genic ones the
exclusive people would you like ones
they only give rise to the one
intermediate so like for instance
alanine only gives rise to pyruvate same
thing with sisty and glycine they only
give rise to pyruvate there okay
so that's kind of what's going on with
glucose genic versus ketogenic amino
acids and you should probably keep that
in mind as we go through the actual
pathways of the oxidation of the carbon
skeletons in the following videos anyway
I hope that video is helpful thank you
for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying